in earlier mathematics that you may have
done you you probably got familiar with
the idea of a factor so for example let
me just pick an arbitrary number the
number 12.
we could say that the number 12 is the
product
is the product of say 2 and 6. 2 times 6
is equal to 12. so because if you take
the product of 2 and 6 you get 12 we
could say that 2 is a factor of 12 we
could also say that 6 is a factor of 12.
you take the product of these things you
get 12. you could even say that this is
this is 12 in factored form people don't
really talk that way but you could think
of it that way that we we broke 12 into
the things that we could use to multiply
it and you probably remember from
earlier mathematics the notion of prime
factorization where you break it up into
all of the prime factors so in that case
you could break the 6 into a 2 and a 3
and you have 2
times 2
times 3 is equal to 12
and you would say well this would be 12
in prime factored form or the prime
factorization of 12. so these are the
prime
prime factors
and so the general idea this this notion
of a factor
is things that you can multiply together
to get your original thing or if you're
talking about factored form you're
thinking you're essentially taking the
number and you're breaking it up into
the things that when you multiply them
together you get your original number
what we're going to do now is extend
this idea into the algebraic domain so
if we start
with an expression now let's say the
expression is 2
plus
4 x
can we break this up into the product of
2 either numbers or two expressions or
the product of a number and an
expression
well one thing that might jump out at
you is we can write this as
we could write this as two times one
plus
x and you can verify if you like that
this does indeed equal 2 plus 4x
2 times we're just going to distribute
the 2 2 times 1 is 2
2 times 2x
is equal to 4x so plus 4x
and so in when we in our in our algebra
brains this will often be
viewed as or referred to as this
expression factored or in a factored
form and in this case or sometimes
people would say that we have factored
out the two but you could just as just
as easily say that you have factored out
a one plus two x you've broken this
thing up into two of its factors so
let's do let's do a couple of examples
of this and then we'll think about you
know i just told you that hey we could
write it this way but how do you
actually figure that out
so let's do another one
let's say that you had i don't know
let's say you had
six let me just in a different color
let's say
you had
six x
plus
three
plus well let's just write it six so 6x
plus 30. that's interesting
so one way to think about it is can we
break up each of these terms so that
they have a common factor
well this one over here i can literally
6x literally represents 6
times x
and then 30 if i want to break out a 6
30 is divisible by 6 so i can write this
as
6 times 5. 30 is the same thing as 6
times 5.
and when you write it this way you see
hey i can factor out a 6. essentially
this is the reverse of the distributive
property
so
i'm essentially undoing the distributive
property taking out the 6 and you are
going to end up with so if you take out
the 6 you end up with 6
times
6 times so if you take out the 6 here
you have an x and you take out the 6
year you have plus 5. so 6x 30 if you
factor it we could write it as 6 times
x plus 5 and you can verify with the
distributive property if you distribute
this 6 you get 6x plus 5 times 6 or 6x
plus 30. let's do something that's a
little bit more interesting where we
might want to factor out a fraction
so let's say we had the situation let me
get a color a new color here
so let's say we had
one half
minus
three halves
minus three halves x
how could we write this in a i guess you
could say in a factored form or if we
wanted to factor out something
and i encourage you to pause the video
and try to try to figure it out and i'll
give you a hint see if you can factor
out one-half
well so let's write it that way if we're
trying to trying to factor out one-half
we can write this first term as
one-half times one and this second one
we could write as
so minus one-half times three
x
that's what this is three halves x is
the same thing as three x divided by two
or one half times three x and then here
we could see that we can just factor out
the one half and you're gonna get one
half
times one
minus
three x
another way you could have thought about
it is hey look both of these are our
products involving one half now it's a
little bit more
confusing when you're when you're
dealing with a fraction here but one way
to think about it is i can divide out a
one-half from each of these terms so if
i divide out a one half from this one
half divided by one half is one and if i
take out if i take three halves and i
divide it by one half that's going to be
three and so i took out a one half
that's another way to think about it i
don't know if that confuses you more or
confuses you less but hopefully this
gives you the sense of what factoring an
expression is and i'll do another
example where we're even using more
abstract things so i could say
ax
plus
a y
how could we write this in fractured
form well these are both both of these
terms have products of a in it so i
could write this as a
times x
plus y and sometimes you'll hear people
say you have factored out the a and you
can verify it if you multiply this out
again if you distribute the a you'd be
left with ax plus a y